you
welcome everyone we'll get started in
just just a minute
all right welcome to leadership for
society um and this season we're talking
about reimagining work post coven and
i'm excited to have three guests today
to talk about um shifting demographics
in the workplace so um our three guests
are laura carstensen professor of
psychology at stanford university i'm
also the founding director of the
stanford center on longevity and the
author of a long bright future happiness
health and financial security in an age
of increased longevity
we also have manu mil manu serves as the
ceo of bridge usa a national
organization that's investing in the
future of democracy
and jennifer liu and jennifer liu is a
workplace reporter for cnbc make it
where she writes about the cultural work
and she also contributes to make its
millennial money franchise a series that
details how people earn spend and save
their money thank you all for agreeing
to be me here today
thanks for having us
great so let me let me start off by just
recognizing something we've all heard a
lot about recently so the workforce is
aging so according um to the u.s well
according to
uh on that the national
um
council on compensation insurance we can
talk about why they're doing these
studies
um the u.s labor force age 65
and older is expected to grow by more
than um 10 percent i'm sorry more than
50 in the next 10 years making it 10
percent of the total labor force
so the workers age 65 and older are
predicted to be more than ten percent of
the total late total labor force the
next 10 years
what challenges and opportunities um do
you see tied to the aging of the
workforce and lara i'd love to hear from
you first
sure
you know i think we hear a lot about the
aging of the workforce
i think the bigger story embedded in
this is the age diversification of the
workforce
so this is the first time in human
history where we have had
uh five and six birth cohorts
working together in the same workforce
at the same time we've just never had
this before so when we talk about aging
workforces it kind of focuses us on
those 65 and older but really the issue
is how do people from very different
backgrounds very different ages work
together in a way that optimizes that
diversity
great and and what what are the
opportunities there i'm curious how you
think about that
the opportunities are enormous in my
view
uh we we don't have a lot of research
yet on
mixed-aged workforces but the
studies that are
here now
suggest that productivity may well go up
so there's a a famous study that was
done at an automobile manufacturing
plant
in europe where they compared
productivity on an assembly line of work
teams that were all young work teams
that were all old and mixed stage work
teams
and what they found is that the mixed
age work teams were most productive of
all
uh the young teams were really fast and
they made a lot of mistakes
and the older teams were slower but they
essentially didn't make mistakes
and the other piece of this from other
studies is that when young people make
mistakes on
in manufacturing and so on they they're
very expensive
when older people make mistakes they're
not as expensive
so the to me the opportunity is you put
the ages together
and you have teams of people where you
have experienced
workers
uh who have lots of knowledge about that
field
and their particular tasks and you mix
them in with young people who are
ambitious and
fast learners and
active and you you see really great
outcomes so we we've seen this kind of
increase in productivity now not just in
assembly line workers but in lots of
different contexts and i think that's
the possibility but the trick is how do
you what is that mix
what's the optimal mix how do you do it
how do you put people together and how
do you make sure everybody's got a voice
in those teams
yeah so i mean what i hear a lot about
lately is the tension between older
workers and and younger workers
um and i'm curious i'm jennifer you
right in this space about the culture of
work
what do you what do you see in terms of
the tensions between younger and older
workers
yeah that's a great question um
earlier this year my team and i at cnbc
make it did a
big
series around
middle-aged millennials um when you
think of millennials in the workplace
you might still think of young
professionals um recent grads when in
fact some of the oldest millennials are
turning 40 this year um and when you
think of
reaching 40 these workers are
you know
reaching or still working towards some
major life milestones starting a family
buying a home paying off student loans
and all that translates to
what they bring
to the workplace
um you know the stereotype that
millennials are young and hungry and
ready to job hop
to find the next best opportunity
um while that is true of all younger
workers um people who are you know in
this kind of middle age reaching middle
management track
um
are feeling these intense personal
pressures
and that impacts the decisions that they
make in their careers as far as going
for promotions um you know finding
opportunities to
advance um there has been you know
decades-long disinvestment in learning
and development programs
in corporate america so the
move moving from employer to employer
um of course is you know leads to
uh attrition and um establishing that
company loyalty
is not
maybe necessarily at the top of
these professionals minds and of course
that can breed some tension between
people who are
younger working toward establishing
themselves in their career have put in
at this point
a decade plus of their lives into their
work but are still having trouble
reaching um levels of management or
leadership
where they see themselves making
decisions and steering the future of a
company or operation
um and maybe not necessarily seeing that
support from senior leaders as well
so i think we have a question what do
you think of is the where is the power
dynamic right now between older and
younger workers
um it's it's interesting because on the
one hand there's certainly ageism in the
country there's no doubt that that is an
issue on the other hand i hear a lot
about younger workers feeling not not
having the opportunity to ascend to
decision making um positions so how do
you all see the
tension or the power dynamic um playing
out right now between older and younger
workers i know i'd love to hear hear
your thoughts
um sure and thank you all so much for
for having me great to be in
conversation with uh jennifer and laura
and i do have to certainly relate to the
the line that laura said at the end
which is that younger teams are a lot
more prone to mistakes as someone that
um uh is now full-time in a dorm room
project i can tell you that
our mistakes far outnumber our successes
and right now we're in a hiring bench
for older workers so
that's sort of the perspective that that
i'm bringing the other perspective i'm
bringing is that it was my first
full-time year of work and i've only
known the pandemic as a
a workspace and that's actually a very
interesting dynamic uh for
when you look at a lot of folks that are
that are especially at the older end of
gen z i don't even know technically if i
qualify as gen z but i don't also
qualify as a millennial um so somewhere
in the middle there but basically you
have this this this string of workers
from the age of about i would say 21 to
23 that have never actually been to the
workplace um and so that is an
interesting dynamic that a lot of people
have to contend with when they do start
opening offices um to your direct
question about
what are sort of the power dynamics and
the opportunities um i think the the
opportunity is that uh that you have a
tremendous opportunity for social
cohesion i mean when you see five
different age cohorts in one place i
mean right now i'm hard-pressed to find
another um area of social space or
impact where you have that much
diversity of views viewpoints and ages i
mean that means that your workplace is
essentially what tocqueville used to
call is your voluntary political
association because i don't know what
else is the town square these days and
so that's what you have that's a huge
opportunity point i'm not just from a
political sense but from my from a
social and melting pot sense um where
we're seeking more and more connection
um but to your point about
i would say power dynamics especially
now i think you actually i think young
people often underestimate the power of
being young in the workplace i mean from
my experience what i've noticed and this
might be very relevant to me but um from
folks that are now entering the
workspace uh there is a lot of
opportunity that a lot of younger people
have had because of their initiative and
drive that they've shown and a lot of
your older power dynamics i don't think
are as relevant in some of your newer
industries especially when you look at
tech venture capital
a lot of the a lot of the industries a
lot of gsb folks will be going into
because
they're a lot more flexible and i think
the success is less age dependent more
experienced dependent um last point that
i would just say in terms of
power dynamics the disadvantage here and
the risk
is that i think you're at a unique
moment in this country's history where
tying and separating work and and
political and social issues is becoming
increasingly more difficult um i'm often
conversations with a lot of industry
leaders where they have to decide
whether or not they have to issue a
statement on let's say the voting rights
bill or you know um various other
cultural issues and i'm not the one
that's trying to bring politics to the
room but that's the decisions that are
being made and so the the dynamic that
that introduces is you have a generation
of value differences at the political
level that can create a lot of tension
in the workplace and i think that is
something that a lot of leaders are
gonna have to contend with
i'm happy you brought up um the kind of
tensions between the generations because
there's you both you and are both um
reference the the broad diversity in the
workplace and the potential benefits
associated with that but if we've
learned anything over the last few years
that diversity can also lead to a lot of
conflict
right and so i'm wondering how you
imagine managing that conflict and it's
it's come up right so you hear people
talking about boomers and disparaging
ways right and and then on the same by
the same token you hear a lot of
negative stereotypes of millennials and
gen z's right
how do you when you bring those people
together how do you create the situation
so that you get the benefits associated
with that diversity as opposed to
getting balkanization like these
fractures along these generational lines
especially with
the differences in like values of
political opinions and and um tied to
those differences
so i'll i'll
well
you go ahead i'd love to
because i was thinking of what manu said
and and i
psychology you know the the
probably the the best
uh supported way to to bring different
kinds of communities together
is by creating a group where everybody's
working toward the same goal
and i think the workplace is an
excellent place for that to happen
because you have the same
the same productivity goal the same
uh output goal and and bringing people
together with different perspectives
when you're working toward the same goal
is really a great way to unite people um
i see the workforce whether paid or
unpaid volunteer workforce is another
way to bring generations together where
you're you're coming together because
you care about something so people are
at work in a particular kind of a
discipline because that's what it
matters to them right so there already
is some uh there are some shared values
and you put them together
and that's where i think you start to
see
lots of common ground
[Music]
and i i would just if i could just add
to that i think
when you're thinking about where
diversity can often produce more uh
discord than than sort of uh what you
were talking about unity towards a
certain goal i think
one of the biggest
factors we've seen in our organization
for example and we work in different
continents and different sort of both at
the university and high school level so
you both have a diversity in gen z
itself but then you have cultural
diversity and on top of that you have
layered age diversity so it's a it's a
diversity melting pot let's just say
that and and the big challenge there
we've noticed is miscommunication and
lack of ability for people to actually
raise concerns and thoughts i think
there's often this especially now um
with our cultural moment workers
regardless of what age you are what you
believe there's just this
everyone is thinking about that certain
thing that's happening in the world and
no one knows how to address it or talk
about it and now your company is talking
about that issue in a public light and
and
the best way i think to capture those
diverse viewpoints is to make and allow
spaces in companies and in spaces for in
organizations for people to have those
conversations to have those smooth
dialogues to to be able to facilitate
intergenerational communication and to
not shy away from the issues that are
often seen as obstacles towards company
productivity but instead use them as
reasons for people to be comfortable and
engage in expressing their views i think
when you cl when you position your
companies very diverse but don't allow
diverse opinions to percolate um
then i think there's a counterintuitive
effect that can actually hinder the
productivity of diversity
i agree couldn't agree more and that
again when we talk about sort of what's
the big story is it an aging workforce
or is it an age-diverse workforce and
then we talk about cohort differences
the differences may really come about
more because of ethnic and racial
diversity as a function of birth cohort
in the country than it does as a
function of age but we tend to
uh
meld those things to conflate them and
so we talk about older people as being
you know
uh
[Music]
more prejudice or bigoted or something
you know but it's it it really reflects
the kind of um population in which they
were born into and grew up with more
than it does age i guess is what i'm
saying so i think we need to be careful
about what we think of as the age
problem and what we think of as a
diversity problem which is real and and
one that we need to
address
and speaking of that how do you so no
matter how open we are to the age
diversity in the workplace there will be
generational shifts right
how do we manage those effectively right
what is the expectation like how when
when should um people who are older make
space for people that are younger is
that a way how should we even think
about that question right how do you
manage generational shifts in power
gracefully
people
people tend to think that of work forces
as zero-sum
games as a fixed pot
and that is not a good way to think of
the workforce you know the more people
who work the more in a population the
more jobs that get created
and so it is in a zero-sum game and we
need to first recognize that
uh
second there
appears to be lots of just sort of
natural
pro-social
investments that older workers have
toward younger workers so there's an
awful lot of
mentoring that goes on
around the water fountain in the
hallways
with older workers helping younger
workers advance their own careers and
that's the kind of really nice
developmental trend that we
uh seemed to to to see
um
berkeley yeah uc berkeley had a program
years ago where they were trying to get
rid of the older professors and so they
were giving people really sweet buy-out
deals you know to go away and and of
course two things happened one was the
the top professors uh just left and got
jobs at other universities and took the
sweet sweetheart deal too to leave um
but what happened is that the assistant
professors were struggling
and because they didn't have older
colleagues who were saying oh you know
you should talk to so-and-so or let me
introduce you to so-and-so or there's an
opportunity for publication here and and
so um i think we need to also be aware
of that they're ten and that's what
tends to happen just naturally when you
put mixed generations together yeah i
mean i i i i hear that and i i see some
of that certainly in the academy of
being a professor i have that experience
but i've also talked to some people who
are i'll just say let's say younger than
i am we should kind of define what we
mean by young because i think people
where the lines are drawn between older
middle-aged and young that varies at the
moment you're talking to but for now
just i'll just stay with the younger
people i talk to let's call it uh under
30.
and some of them are expressing um
i would say
anger toward older generations and
here's here's something that i hear and
i'm gonna
push this to you jennifer in a second
like the older generation basically
leveraged our future to take care of
themselves
they left us this mess with the climate
um and now we can't we're at an age
where they could buy homes we can't buy
homes right now we can't afford to have
families right now and all of this is in
part because of the way our you know our
people ahead of us
managed their the economy for their own
benefit at the expense at our expense so
i'm curious jennifer and you because you
work on with thinking about some
millennials and maybe younger folks is
that something that you hear and how do
you think about um how that's playing
out in terms of this dynamic this age is
age dynamic
yeah certainly i've absolutely heard
those exact sentiments from
numerous
sources that i've spoken with over the
past few months
um
and i mean
there are certainly um you know
anecdotal experiences that they can draw
from on their you know what they see in
their own workplace dynamic as well as
macro level you know
shifts in the
economy and the labor market
um
i think
the key is going back to laura what you
brought up um there's a huge opportunity
for
mentorship in the workplace and i think
that could help um bridge some of the
divides um and address some of the
tensions that uh you know if uh younger
workers
don't see that they have a like upward
path within their uh position or their
role at a certain company but being
paired with someone who has been with
the employer for
a longer period of time it can draw from
you know
their years of experience to draw them
up um and i think
a big issue especially for younger
workers is not seeing you know what is
my contribution to this organization
like am i just following the footsteps
of someone else um but i think having
that dialogue in that
you know two-way street brainstorming
this is how things have been
done
but also recognizing and finding value
in bringing in new ideas
could
ease some of that tension
and you know i i would just say that
when it comes to
when you're thinking about
sort of the animosity that younger
generations have towards older
generations i'm going to go a little bit
against the grain and sort of the
consensus here and actually disagree a
little bit with that in that
what i've found is not so much
across the board sort of gen z and
younger millennials i'm supposed to be
talking about i would say
um
23 to sort of 27 and then people from 18
to 23. so that's sort of the age range
that i'm talking about if we're trying
to be specific
and
it's not so much a criticism of older
generations that i've seen across the
board that certainly exist to sort of
jennifer's point i mean you you hear
that certainly on the coast and you hear
that especially with students that are
graduating from elite universities but
that's the key difference is the other
big strain that i've seen is actually
more of an anti-elitism an
anti-institutional
ethic
an anti-authority
you'll see this in very basic things
like the number one political podcast
right in the country is not from your
establishment news outlets it's actually
from independent journalists the reason
why things like sub stack clubhouse um
i'm joined these trends are catching on
is because the younger workforce is
actually a lot more focused on
criticizing trust and institutions and
less focused i think of policy issues
and that
the policy issues might manifest in in
sort of that anti-institutional critique
but
when i look at it as anti-institutional
as opposed to their their critical of
climate whether they're critical of how
the older generation's handled xyz i
think that's the that's sort of been the
more unifying trend and you think about
it this way you know anyone that's my
age or older um sort of under 30 the
four main events that have defined our
lived history are 9 11 the great
recession the 2016 election the 2020
election slash the pandemic those are
four big
failures of institutions and so
that is what has i've noticed sparked
and thought about how young people are
really approaching this problem unless
based on um hey you know the the older
folks are have screwed this up or that
up because i certainly know at least
from my angle that um this seems to be
the case that every younger generation
says about the older generation it's
like hey that older generation's worse
that older generation's worse and then
it seems like everyone screws it up so
who really is the culprit
and all the old older generations are
always talking about those slacker young
people i mean they certainly were
talking about that when when when i was
in my 20s and 30s you know you were out
there protesting the vietnam war you
know and stuff and they're like yeah you
know
these kids they don't know anything and
um yeah i think there is some something
to that there are these stereotypes that
i think are are um more pervasive than
than actual
experience with people of different ages
in the workforce that is that the
stereotypes are stronger than the
behaviors uh lots of young people work
with older workers and
older workers with younger and and they
don't think of them as older or younger
they think of them as mary and joe you
know and and and
you get to that and
and i think that's again a way that work
can bring people together as opposed to
to separate them but jennifer i i think
there's really something true to this uh
um
you know old joe is sitting in that ceo
spot and as long if he's going to work
to lady you know
what do i do you know what what what
what what happens to the bench you know
and what happens to young people when
older workers stay in jobs for a long
period of time and uh with the what what
i i believe is is happening there is
that's real in some companies
um and
but it is not true for the macro level
economy at the macro level as i was
saying earlier the more older people in
the workforce the more money there is to
spend and the more jobs that get created
so at one level
um there's no evidence for that but not
if you work in that company where old
joe was sitting at the top and so there
is something real uh to that and younger
worker younger people today are just
facing a really hard time in history
uh they're not getting ahead uh the
rates that their parents did they're not
able to to buy homes as young as their
parents did or pay off debt at the same
rates or start families and we're seeing
all of that kind of get reflected
through
lots of different milestones and younger
people are reaching those milestones at
older ages than their prior generations
did
and this is a problem
um i i i would resist blaming it on
older generations like you did this
because i don't think any you know
i'm not aware of having done that you
know and so on but but it's happened and
i think all of us need to look at that
and figure out a way that all of us can
help younger people do better
so what do you attribute it to so i mean
i think there's no i mean the evidence
is just clear on this right the younger
people are reaching those milestones at
later years so that that's just object
seems to be objectively true
what do you attribute that to i'm
curious if anyone can weigh in here
because you know what i understand you
don't want to attribute it to the
behavior of older people but
i don't i don't i'm curious what the
attribution is the research looks like
it's about money
uh when you graduate from school and
you've got a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
you don't get married you don't have
kids you don't buy a house you don't
start a retirement account because
you've got to pay off the debt and
that's what's happening that looks like
you know and the financial analysis that
my colleagues have done at the longevity
center it looks like that's what's
accounting for this
at the root of it it's having the
resources to be able to move forward
one more thing to this though this has
been going on for generations
um jallu streeter and
some of her colleagues again at the
center did a study where they compared
different cohorts
um in what they said the ideal age was
to
get married to have kids to buy a house
and then she asked people of different
cohorts and when did you get the to that
age and for generations
the age at which people achieve these
milestones has been getting older so
this isn't something that suddenly
appeared
in today's youth it's been getting older
and older gradually for decades
the sad part is
that the ideal age at which these
milestones are achieved hasn't changed a
bit
so young people today are saying i
should have own a home by the time i'm
30.
most people aren't but the idea that's
the perception and i think that's what
also contributes to people feeling like
they're being left behind or they're not
on track uh there's something wrong with
them individually but in fact these
trends have been going on for a long
long time
and i mean some some people attribute
that to a divestment and um
support of human capital in particular
education right and so i wonder how it
like this takes us kind of to politics
right because that's basically that's
policy and you could argue that the the
people in um power politically are are
aging and that that might be somewhat
zero-sum right and unlike the workforce
so i wonder how you think about the
aging and politics should we should we
try to
do something about the way our political
system works in terms of term limits or
something else to make sure the
diversity we see say example and for
example in the workplace is also
reflected among the people who are
making decisions in terms of policy
before i
oh sorry go ahead laura no i was just
putting thumbs up
yeah no no before before i answer that
that um that question directly the one
issue that i've noticed that really
affects politics right now and and you
see this across sort of the last couple
of decades
is is is not just um an age issue but
actually a brain drain i mean writ large
you see your smartest people not going
into public service they're not going to
social causes they're not going into
basic public institutions that actually
affect every piece of your daily life um
like you want your smartest mckinsey
slash whatever the case might be and i
can say that because i'm at the gsb if
we were in kansas i would not be saying
the mckinsey consultant but here we can
say that you want them going to be your
mayor to run your local city council you
need people to be using basic business
skills that you learn and you're not
seeing that and i think and this is the
connection the reason why that exists is
because you see your role models and
politics being so old i think
there's one this stigma that you can
like only enter politics once your hair
starts growing and i mean that's only
reinforced by the fact that the current
for example one of the senators on the
republican side just agreed to run for
re-election he's 88 his name chuck
grassley um i mean nothing against
senator grassley but that you know
that's a really old age um and you can
cast your own judgment on that but that
i mean the fact that those are your role
models and that's the age there's just
an issue there with you're not going to
have your younger people going in the
second i think um issue with regards to
having um older politicians in power is
that naturally change happens and you
want your leaders to be associated and
understand that change very
strategically a core example of this is
the hearings around social media
companies i mean the the the amount of
fun that that senators and members of
congress got made of because they didn't
know what facebook was is you know you
can't be governing when you don't
understand the policies and so we can
fix that you know we can educate engage
but again i think there's a broader
issue and it gets to your question um dr
lowry that do you want term limits do
you want some sort of institutional
check i think across the board and again
this goes to the point of
anti-institutionalism anti-elitism
there's a strain and anxiety against um
people that have been in power for a
really long time a really old ceo for
example is i i think term limits are
supported across the board and not just
by
younger people but also by older
politicians um one of the the big fears
that a lot of political leaders have and
actually by folks like for example nancy
pelosi recently said in an interview the
reason why she's still in office is not
because she wants to be but because
she's scared that no one else is there
to take the mantle so they're not going
to say necessarily that they're there
because they want to hang out i mean i i
totally understand a lot of them want to
go off and and and do their things
beyond politics but there's a
nervousness and anxiety that people
aren't there ready to take up the mantle
so you have this vicious cycle where new
talent isn't coming in older talent is
staying because of that and as a result
you only have your oldest talent at the
top
should that be afraid
didn't you just tell me that young
people are anti-institutions why would i
want an anticipation person running the
government
well see that's there's a difference
there it's not that they're
anti-institution in the sense that they
hate the government it's that there's a
mistrust in the current leadership of
various institutions um it's not that
you know people hate people in suits
right no one you know that the idea you
have to control the institutions to
create change it's that there's a
mistrust and distrust in how those
institutions have been operating which
is different because no one's trying to
burn down institutions people are just
trying to reform them which is which is
a critical distinction
okay i think this is where
uh incubators and organizations that can
help identify
um people to run for elected office and
support them and help fundraise and have
those resources draw from i mean
making the decision to run for office it
requires um
having a job that gives you that
flexibility to campaign and if you win
to take on those responsibilities and
maintain a paid job with a wage you know
afford your lifestyle um you know
for a lot of
um
public servant jobs it the the pay is
just not there for it to be you know
this aspirational career you don't go
into it for the money um
but you
it all comes back to you know
money um you know if people don't have a
lot of the financial resources
uh to be able to support themselves as
they
continue on this uh
additional you know goal of theirs
they're not going to feel that there is
space for them to give it a shot
i mean for perspective the the salary of
uh you know um a senate page or senate
clerk right who's just working the hill
first year out is i think 32 000 no
bonuses and the most basic insurance
benefits and they are very smart
intelligent people but why would you in
your right mind choose to go live in dc
um and be paid thirty two thousand
dollars it's just not going to cut it um
and so i think i think jennifer is
absolutely right that you have to think
about pay there is a little bit of a
fear of opening up incubation
competitions on on political things and
and the fear around that um is whether
or not
um
it just depends on who's running those
competitions and what are the standards
and what are the rules um
but that's not a conversation when you
hear it there
but on the same page
we do live in a gerundocracy and it is a
problem um
we are being governed by a very very
old white male
elite group of people and um although
there have been some changes in that
there haven't been enough changes in it
what i would add to the need for younger
people representing
populations in dc
would be some kinds of policies
that would
review any kinds of new legislation
to evaluate how it will affect different
generations
a colleague of mine at harvard lisa
berkman has been advocating for this so
that we would have some kind of a a
committee let's say you're going to
increase uh payments and social security
and what you would have to do before you
did that you could do it and you could
advocate for it whatever but you have to
say this is what it's going to do
for people who are 10 years younger 20
years younger 30 years younger and so
that we'd be able to see that you can
imagine the same kinds of things for
climate
um and all sorts of different kinds of
policies that could be advocated i think
we have reached this point with an age
diverse society where we need to think
deeply about how the the changes that we
advocate for are going to affect not
just the current generation but future
generations
i still have one more question for each
of you
what do you think is the most pressing
issue what would you want to leave
people thinking about with respect to
age and reimagining work what we need to
do to have a
vibrant
workforce and society going forward it's
the most pressing issue in your mind
laura do you want to go first
sure
it's a lack of imagination
we need to ask the question what are the
opportunities here and instead we have
this white knuckle approach of bracing
for the fall and oh my gosh you know
we're gonna have too many old people in
the workforce and what's gonna happen to
the young people and we're just and
instead we need to just kind of
take a step back for a minute and say
here's the workforce today because
people are going to work longer and
we're going to have old people we know
that now
and to start to say
how do we exploit that
optimally in ways that uh improve life
for for everybody
and that's the question
and and i think we spend a lot of time
worrying about the problems and what we
really should be doing is thinking about
solutions and new opportunities
great jennifer what do you think
yeah i think related um
i mean
the way that so many people have been
working in the last 18 months is
completely different from what they have
known before
it has presented such opportunity in the
way of
flexible work
that i think you know a main challenge
up to
uh the people in charge is
understanding how
uh workplaces can be flexible and
accommodate the needs of their employees
at various life stages um right now i'm
doing some reporting on
uh
women being forced out of the labor
force um due to ongoing child care
and dependent care needs
um
but
employers have shown that they have the
resources if they want to invest in
women and invest in underrepresented
employees they have the levers to pull
on
um and that varies so much uh throughout
um life stages into you know the aging
workforce and i think there's so much
opportunity there that um
we can really be pushing for
uh manu what do you think
yeah i think
uh i'll just give an example of our
organization so we actually faced the
totally opposite problem which is that
we just too many young people and and
the entire dynamic is focused on young
people now that's for good reason
because we're student-led movement and
we're trying to improve the way that
young people are having conversations so
you want young people to help but
actually the problem that we're running
into now is that there's both a lack of
experience and also um we want smarter
people than us in our leadership team so
we can be making better decisions and so
this goes to laura's point which is
that's our situation so how do we fix it
it wasn't thinking about older young
people it was who can fill this skill
gap which is we need experience we need
smarter folks we need people that have
made mistakes in the past so they can
get better and they can teach us so we
have to make those mistakes who fits the
bill people lots of experience who's got
lots of experience older people and so i
think rather than looking at the
situation as sort of laura's describing
jennifer there was just saying in
relation how the workplace is structured
is it's not necessarily a problem it's
just a situation the situation is that
we've got
huge age gaps and you've got a lot of
old people a lot of young people it's a
situation it's not a problem yet um the
problem becomes when we look at it as
something that's insurmountable but
actually it's filling a huge value gap i
mean right now
your younger folks are bringing in a
very diverse and interesting perspective
they've got new skills they've got new
technologies
and you can harness the older wisdom to
not be obstacles to that but to be jet
fuel to propel that forward without
making the mistakes that they've made in
the past
great well all of you are very
optimistic about the future i really
appreciate that and i hope that the way
things develop um support that optimism
but i really i really appreciate the
time that you all took and talking to
you all tonight so thanks so much for
taking the time
thanks brian thank you for moderating
thank you yeah thanks so next week i'll
be joined by rachel carlson of guild
education and david osborne the author
of
reinventing america schools to discuss
education so i hope that you all join
then thanks so much have a good night
okay